Luffy, Law, and Kid combined forces to take
down the monstrous Emperors Big Mom and
Kaido. But each of them are so incredibly
different. Law is a master tactician. Kid
is a mechanical genius. And Luffy brings
freedom everywhere he goes. So instead of
these three fighting against each other for
most of the story, I wonder exactly how well
they would work together on one crew. And
since we are putting these three together,
let’s explore the wild crew dynamics if the ENTIRE
Worst Generation were all together on one crew.
And of course it is nearly impossible for
all of these characters to randomly meet
up at the start of their pirate adventures.
So instead we are simply going to put them
all together on one ship as they fly down
Reverse Mountain and they suddenly have to
figure out how to be a crew. Which of
course means that the first thing this
wildly competitive group must figure
out is who is going to be the captain?
So how are they going to do that? Well,
they could play some sort of pirate game,
like a Davy Back fight or a treasure hunt, but
I honestly think they would settle for just a
straight up fight to see who is the strongest.
So let’s imagine they draw a massive circle and
the last one standing in the ring gets to
be captain. Now you might think that Luffy
or even Captain Kid with his magnetic devil
fruit are the favorites to win this fight,
but man are you going to be shocked by the outcome
of this insane clash. Because right at the start,
Trafalgar Law uses his Ope Ope fruit to instantly
teleport Luffy and Kid outside the ring.
Bam. Two down already. Not as
simple as you thought, right?
Because remember if we are imagining them at the
start of the Grand Line then Luffy definitely
wouldn’t have any of his major power ups yet and
on top of that none of them really know what each
other’s fruits can do. So with Luffy and Kid
grumbling on the sideline, the rest of the crew
battle it out for the right to be captain. Zoro
and Killer clash blades. Hawkins uses his straw
man powers and Capone enters his Big Father mode
as they team up against the Mad Monk Urouge. Then
across the battlefield the age manipulating
Jewelry Bonney is having a tough time against
the dinosaur-man X Drake as the musical man Apoo
attacks with his explosive musical devil fruit.
And at this point you might have realized that we
have technically left out one member of the worst
generation. That is of course Blackbeard,
who yes of COURSE we are leaving out. Did
you think we were going to include ANOTHER
Yonko into this already busted crew? Also,
let’s be real here, Blackbeard
would never get along with most
of the people on this crew and might just
end up killing everyone in their sleep.
So, with no Teach there, who
do you think came out on top?
Well, I think that because this first time they
are all together, it is incredibly difficult for
anyone to overcome Law’s broken abilities.
I mean he can basically teleport people,
cut them in half, or swap personalities. Which all
just seems like too much for anyone to figure out
right in the middle of an intense battle. So Law
wins the battle royale, and thanks to Urouge’s
ability to tank pain and turn it into power, the
Mad Monk ends up in second and with the role of
Vice-Captain. For now… But this won’t be the last
time they battle it out, because I think this
crew would adopt a system similar to Kaido’s crew,
where the entire crew can challenge the other crew
members to move up the ranks. So keep watching to
find out how long Luffy and Kid are at the bottom.
Honestly though, it is probably the best possible
outcome for Law to be Captain right now because he
is the most careful and tactical out of anyone of
the Worst Generation. Which means that he should
be able to AT LEAST get them to properly sail
the ship to make it to the first island of the
Grand Line. I mean can they even call themselves
a crew if they can’t even do that? Or wait,hold
on. I just remember Law actually uses a submarine,
so maybe he doesn’t even know how to sail. Whoops.
But let’s forget about that for now. Because
there are WAY MORE IMPORTANT things to discuss.
Because the most important part of any crew
is the actual roles the crew takes. Now we
already said Law is Captain and Urouge is
Vice-Captain, but here are the other roles
I think work best for the other crew members. And
while you can argue for or against many of these,
I based them mostly on the hobbies and interests
the author has told us about these characters.
For example, Bonney and Killer would both
open restaurants if they weren’t pirates
which means they should at least know how to
cook. Plus X Drake enjoys studying the stars,
which would make him a pretty
good navigator, in my opinion.
So with that all settled they’re off on their
pirate adventure, but will this wild crew be
able to succeed and find the One Piece? Keep
watching to find out, but for now there’s
no real way of knowing which of the seven
paths from Reverse Mountain that this crew
will take. They could take the same one Luffy
took and visit Drum island, Alabasta, Jaya,
and others, or they could take a completely
different path that we don’t really know. The
one thing that is going to happen NO MATTER
WHAT is the war at Marineford. Because this
single event COMPLETELY BROKE the peaceful
balance of the world. And once Luffy hears
that his brother Ace had been captured he
will ABSOLUTELY DEMAND that the crew go to
save his brother. And CAN YOU EVEN IMAGINE the
split this would cause the crew. On one hand,
characters like Kid and Urouge would probably
love to go and fight in the massive war. On the
other hand, more careful characters like Hawkins
and Capone would probably want to stay far away.
And there is no doubt that Law, who is still
captain at this point, would flat out say no.
Which would lead to a massive brawl because
there is no way Luffy is letting his brother
get executed without a fight. Although I
suppose Luffy could just leave the crew,
but since the point is to keep them together,
let’s imagine that Luffy challenges Law for
the right to be captain. And at this point,
I bet Law would probably be sick and tired of
being captain of these stubborn pirates, so he
might just step down anyways. But even if he does
fight Luffy has grown MUCH STRONGER in the first
half of the grand line. So combine that with his
better understanding of Law’s devil fruit, Luffy
would probably be able to overcome the Surgeon
and everyone else to become the new captain.
Which means we now have our second official Worst
Generation Crew roles, so make sure to subscribe
to the channel for official Worst Generation
merch coming soon. Just kidding, but seriously,
subscribe to the channel for more interesting What
Ifs just like this, but now here are the updated
crew roles. The only major changes being that
Luffy is captain, Kid is Vice-Captain while Law
is now just the doctor and Urouge has some other
role on the crew like shipwright or something.
Although, now that I’m thinking about it, I’m
not sure Kid would even want to be Vice-Captain,
so maybe he stays as a chore boy or simple
fighter and Zoro can be the Vice-Captain.
And with Luffy as Captain things are
about to get WILD. Because there is no
stopping this group from charging straight into
Marineford and causing MASSIVE CHAOS. Because
even though none of these characters
have reached their full potential yet,
they are all still incredibly strong. In fact,
I’d put all of them at least above the lower
tier of Warlords like Moria. Which yeah isn’t
the strongest, but having ELEVEN of them on the
battlefield fighting against the marines could be
enough to completely change the result of the war.
One thing that wouldn’t change is Luffy
teaming up with Whitebeard. And with way
more strong fighters, the marines would have
so much more to deal with. That could mean
the admirals get distracted and need to fight
way more people or maybe Luffy’s Grandpa has
to jump into the battle to help out. Plus
some of the devil fruits that the Worst
Generation Crew bring to the battle are STUPIDLY
OVERPOWERED for this situation. For example,
Kid’s magnetic powers could basically take
all the swords and guns away from the marine
soldiers. Zoro would also love the chance
to fight the world’s strongest swordsman,
Mihawk, again, and Apoo’s musical blasts
would be deadly in this large scale battle.
But probably the MOST IMPORTANT ability
is Law’s teleportation techniques which
could easily move Ace and Luffy to safety when
this magma crazy admiral tries to kill them.
Which means that ACE LIVES! I know, I know a
very unusual circumstance for my What if videos,
but it’s not all positive because I do think
that since Whitebeard was already going all
out that he would still probably die during
the battle. Which means Blackbeard could
still take his devil fruit and go on to
become an Emperor. But now with Ace safe,
the Worst Generation crew retreats along with
the rest of the Whitebeard pirate alliance.
But, wow, this outcome is going to
change A LOT. Because with Ace alive,
he would likely go off with the rest of the
Whitebeard pirates. And who knows, they might
not really want to avenge their fallen captain and
instead might continue as a major force in the New
World instead of being wiped out by Blackbeard.
But one thing we HAVE TO DISCUSS is the timeskip.
If you remember this was originally when Luffy
learned the basics of haki. Now I don’t think
Luffy would be able to spend two years training
AND be able to keep this wild crew together,
so maybe Marco from Whitebeard’s crew gives
Luffy and the others a crash course in haki
as a thanks for saving Ace. Or maybe Luffy’s
original teacher Rayleigh would still show
up and teach him. So basically they all learn
haki and are ready to head into the new world.
However, this is where things could ALL
FALL APART. Because now there are a few very
important points to consider. First, Luffy has
probably awakened his conqueror’s haki by now,
meaning he is truly a candidate to be pirate
king. Second, this was also the part of the
story that many of the Worst Generation gave
up on becoming pirate king. For example,
many of them joined either the Emperors
Big Mom or Kaido’s crews or just straight
up gave up on their dream of finding the
One Piece. So all that means many of the
Worst Generation might actually be fine
truly accepting Luffy as Captain since he
is on the path to becoming an Emperor as
well. However, Kid is the one exception,
because he is basically the only one besides
Luffy who is still truly fighting to be pirate
king this deep into the story. But for now let’s
imagine he doesn’t quite leave. At least yet.
Which means we have to ask: what do they do
next? Well, the crew could still very easily
follow the path to Dressrosa to achieve Law’s
dream of killing Doflamingo. That could once
again lead them to this giant Elephant where
the crew would learn about the Road Poneglyphs,
which are these Red Stones that basically have
directions to Laugh Tale. Which means that it now
makes a ton of sense for the crew to split up to
go after the Road Poneglyphs owned by the Emperors
Kaido and Big Mom. So half the crew goes to Whole
Cake Island and the other half goes to Wano.
Honestly though, this would probably go
very poorly for both groups if they try
to go for a straight up fight. I can just imagine
Bonney’s food cravings going absolutely wild in
Whole Cake Island and exposing the group as soon
as they set foot on the island. And in Wano there
is definitely no one who can take down Kaido at
this point. But let’s imagine they somehow manage
to slip in and steal the poneglyph on whole cake
island, even without the true MVP Brook. I mean,
they have stronger fighters than the normal group
who went to Whole Cake Island, plus Capone can
make a pretty good plan, so it is certaintly
be possible to survive as long as they don’t
get caught by Big Mom. That leads everyone back to
Wano where the raid on Kaido’s castle could mostly
take place like normal. And I am pretty sure
that on average this group is stronger than the
straw hat crew, so who knows the fight against
the King of the Beasts could be even easier.
Which all means that the Worst Generation crew is
SO CLOSE to finding the One Piece and are ready
to take on the remaining Emperors. But hold on!
SURELY it won’t be that easy! Not with this crew.
Because while I’m sure they would have bonded
a lot over their adventures, and some of them
might even be close friends like Luffy and Bonney,
I can just imagine something going HORRIBLY WRONG.
Like this would be the perfect opportunity for
Kid to backstab Luffy and take the poneglyphs
copies or something like that. And if this does
happen it is probably because this crew wouldn’t
have nearly the level of loyalty that the other
Straw Hats like Usopp, Nami, and Chopper have
towards Luffy. I mean Luffy literally had to
save each of the Weakling Trio’s home islands,
but I wonder if they would have still needed
saving if they had eaten an overpowered devil
fruit like oh say, the Luffy’s Nika fruit.
And if you want to see just how unbelievably
incredible Sun God Nami or Joy Boy Usopp’s stories
would get, you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching, and
I’ll see you in the next one.